el dios que goes
no fue una gran noche para no matar y un
hito para la directora china
acribillados para los cineastas
asiáticos y creo que para todos los
realizadores tenemos que ser fieles a
quienes somos tenemos que contar
historias con las que nos sintamos
conectados no deberíamos sentir que solo
hay algunos tipos de historia que
deberíamos contar es una forma de
conectar con otras personas por eso amo
dirigido hacia maker
yao es una pionera es la primera mujer
asiática en ganar la estatuilla a mejor
directora y la segunda mujer en los 93
años de la ceremonia en recibir el
galardón
tomatlán también ganó mejor película en
un año de aislamiento la cinta sobre
viajeros que abandonan la sociedad tras
la crisis financiera de 2008 llamó la
atención entre el jurado de los oscar la
humedad es un híbrido experimental de
drama y documental
tomatlán cuenta la historia de fermín
interpretada por francés mcdormand quien
triunfó como mejor actriz sin test pero
conoce a una comunidad de nómadas
estadounidenses actores naturales que
viven fuera del sistema
mientras que en años anteriores los
oscar recibieron fuertes críticas por su
falta de diversidad este año hubo mejora
de cabez daniel carubia ganó como mejor
actor de reparto por su papel en judas
and the black men saya
y john como actriz de reparto por su
actuación en mi nariz
[Música]
y muchas gracias me gustaría agradecer a
mis dos chicos que me hicieron salir y
trabajar este es el resultado de que
mamá trabajará tanto con anthony hopkins
ganó el premio a mejor actor por su
papel en the father interpretando a un
anciano con demencia los asistentes a la
ceremonia no llevaron mascarillas pero
cumplieron un estricto aislamiento y se
realizaron tres pruebas de antigua el
número de asistentes fue reducido y
algunas estrellas se acogieron a la
videoconferencia